some breaking news to bring you we're  just hearing that um  there has been a resignation from the  dup edwin puts the leader of the dep  has resigned after only 30 days  in office he has released a statement  this evening speaking this evening  this is what he said i've asked the  party chairman to commence an electoral  process within the party  to allow for a new leader of the  democratic unionist party to be elected  the party has asked me to remain in post  until my successor is elected this has  been a difficult period for the party in  the country  and i've conveyed to the chairman my  determination to do everything i can  to ensure both unionism and northern  ireland is able to move forward  to a stronger place so the breaking news  uh this  hour that edwin puts has resigned as the  leader of  the dup will of course keep you updated  on further developments as they come  into us throughout the course of the  evening